question elle met bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors que mike
pompéo se rend donc au soudan avec le
premier vol officiel et historique entre
tel aviv et khartoum pour reprendre les
mots avant le décollage d'un responsable
israélien
qu'est-ce que cela signifie on va
écouter c'est quand même une nouvelle a
fait important enfin plus plus
qu'importante
c'est un un changement de politique dont
les relations entre les états unis et le
soudan d'abord des relations ont été
bien sûr distendues mais mais pas
interrompu surtout en matière de
renseignement est ce ce ce que fait
maintenant le gouvernement américain
s'est donné au soudan la possibilité des
ciments de reprendre un peu de souffle
de reprendre un peu les moyens de se
développer de régler cette multitude de
problèmes qu'il peut avoir en lui
donnant la clé de la créa grandes
institutions financières internationales
et à des accords binationaux et c'est
bon c'est une avancée pour les
etats-unis et pour israël considérable
sur le plan de la sécurité de la région
fera uniquement pour le soudan quels que
soient présents encore loin mais ce
qu'il y à des risques du côté soudanais
à l'intérieur de cette prise de position
il va falloir voir les ruelles les
réactions ces jours-ci de certaines
l'opposition soudanaise tristian elle
met à après l'accord de normalisation on
en a beaucoup parlé des relations entre
israël et les émirats sous la houlette
de washington
que cherche aujourd'hui les américains
en favorisant d'autres accords de ce
type notamment avec le soudan est les
américains cherchent à renforcer la
position leurs alliés dans la région
dont conflit qui les oppose tout de même
à léran s'agit donc de renforcer la
sécurité d'israël est le noyau régional
de ceux qui peuvent mettre un frein aux
locaux politique iranienne bon c'est ça
l'intérêt le sous-tendent devient après
l'egypte sur le terrain africain devient
un partenaire de la collaboration et de
la sécurité régionale alors alors parmi
les pays que mike pompéo va visiter le
soudan donc le bahreïn les émirats
arabes unis on l'a évoqué quelles vont
être les pays les plus frileux
selon vous à cette normalisation écouter
les pays arabes ont toujours refusé
toutes relations avec israël tant qu'on
n'aura pas réglé la question
palestinienne non c'était ça le
protocole pour l'instant on nous dit de
ronde les américains et les israéliens
dire que cet accord avec les pays
d'arabes permettra au contraire de
régler la sphère d'été des peines dans
les styles yens et 1 6 2 peut-être de
rouvrir la question de l'existence de
deux états dans le terrible dans la
région bon c
c'est quelque chose qui est qui qui est
envisageable en pensez mais les pays
d'autres pays âmes sont réticents lebon
l'arabie saoudite elle n'est pas tout à
fait hostile même s'engage pas à fond
dans cette affaire bon on peut parler
parler des songes vous êtes apparaissent
et c'est parler de 2,2 de la jourdanie
de de l'image de la syrie
les pays ne seront jamais d'accord avec
une reprise des relations des deux
l'heure le gouvernement
l'art et israël c'est pas maintenant
c'est pas aujourd'hui que ça va se jouer
pour pour conclure en quelques mots
christian delmet on a parlé un de la
vente d'armes éventuelle des américains
aux émirats arabes unis des avions f-35
est ce que les américains pourraient
aussi trouver des avantages commerciaux
avec ces rapprochements
pourquoi on fait quoi faire no love qui
confirme le soudan en ce qui concerne le
soudan et l'armement notamment la vendée
et hervé bon certain dépit en dépit de
la mise à l'index du pays
le soudan a toujours été un
collaborateur efficace avec la fille par
exemple bons et certains produits comme
parrain de la gomme arabique était tout
de même disponibles pour le marché
américain
maintenant est-ce que cet accord va
permettre de développer notre relation
avec l'épisode s'est passé pas demain
qu'on va donner aux paysans les moyens
technologiques pour éventuellement
relancer une machine défavorable à
israël
pour l'instant la faire et surtout sur
le plan diplomatique le prix politique
pas tellement sur les avantages
économiques que se donnerait aux états
unis dans la région
merci beaucoup christian delmet est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes ethnologue chercheur associé
au centre d'études des mondes africains